monsieur kozic oui merci madame la
Présidente donc le présent amendement
déposé au nom du groupe socialiste vise
à supprimer la nouvelle baisse de CVAE
proposée par le gouvernement au mépris
de l'équilibre des comptes publics et
des besoins de financement de nos
politiques publiques les cadeaux aux
entreprises et au plus aisés sans
contrepartie aucune ne peuvent plus
constituer l'alpha l'alpha et l'oméga de
la politique économique du gouvernement
d'ailleurs monsieur le le ministre je
voudrais aussi revenir sur la sur la la
manière dont a été décider cette
suppression de de de
CVAE un simple coup coup de téléphone
donné par votre Ministre de tutelle la
veille de son intervention le 12
septembre sur LCI va entériner une
décision aussi importante que la
suppression de la CVAE cette décision
très verticale n'a évidemment pas été
prise à la suite des consultations
d'association d'élus et pour cause elles
étaient toutes opposées à cette
suppression à rebours de ce que vous
pouvez déclarer dans la presse il y a eu
un manque
d'écoute de l'ensemble des élus vous
allez m'argumenter dans dans votre
réponse j'anticipe que vous allez
assurer la une compensation pour ma part
je suis pas
convaincu mais je crois qu'au-delà des
logiques comptable c'est aussi cette
mesure n'est pas uniquement une question
de finan publi en supprimant la CV
vous supprimez bien plus qu'une ligne
comptable dans le budget de l'État c'est
une conception de la décentralisation
que vous remettez en cause les maires
nous le disent vous le disent il y a une
nécessité de faire contribuer les
entreprises au financement des services
dont ell et leurs salariés sont
bénéficiaires en supprimant cet article
vous rompez le lien fiscal entre les
collectivités et leurs administrés mais
ce qui est bien plus dommageable c'est
qu'incidemment c'est le contrat social
qui se voit en cause et c'est ce contrat
social qui unit localement entreprise et
territoire et qui permet de partager un
destin commun local et par cette par
cette suppression c'est ce que vous
remettez en cause c'est pour ça que nous
sollicitons la suppression de cet
article